bonsoir bienvenue dans savouregarde ce
soir la ministre chargée de construire
le nouveau modèle français sur la fin de
vie c'est sans doute le projet doit le
plus sensible le plus complexe de ce
quinquennat bonsoir Agnès firmalleau
bonsoir et merci de passer l'heure avec
nous il y aura donc bien une nouvelle
loi sur la fin de 10 c'est la promesse
qu'a fait Emmanuel Macron hier à la
Convention citoyenne laquelle
précisément on va en parler longuement
tout à l'heure dans la deuxième partie
mais on va commencer ce soir avec la fin
de l'intérim surpayer à l'hôpital depuis
hier les salaires des médecins
intérimaires sont strictement plafonnés
la garde de 24 heures à 4000 euros c'est
terminé la fin d'une dérive choquante
certes mais qui n'est pas sans
conséquence surtout en plein contexte de
pénurie de soignants alors est-ce que le
remède est pire que le mal grand débat
dans un instant sur ce plateau avec nos
invités avant de retrouver à 20h15 les
parties pris de nous affranchis et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu
vous me suivez madame je suis et bien
c'est parti
[Musique]
comment mettre fin aux dérives sans
pénaliser l'accès aux soins depuis hier
donc le coup prêt est tombé les
rémunérations des médecins intérimaires
sont plafonnées mais avec quelles
conséquences dans les hôpitaux les plus
éloignés des centres-villes les effets
pervers dans les déserts médicaux là où
la pénurie est criante se font déjà
sentir bonsoir stéphanieiste bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau c'est vous qui
portez ce texte et la loi risque qui
donc est entrée en vigueur hier vous
êtes député renaissance du Loiret et
vous êtes également rapporteur du budget
de la Sécurité sociale en face de vous
ce soir docteur Eric Riboli bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être là médecin
urgentiste et président du Syndicat
national des médecins remplaçant des
hôpitaux vous représentez donc les
fameux médecins intérimaire qui pour
certains d'entrepreneurs tous sont
qualifiés de mercenaires par le ministre
de la Santé vous réagirez évidemment à
ce mot bonsoir Bruno megardman
professeur megardman ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau chef du service
en réanimation à l'hôpital Lariboisière
Paris grand hôpital parisien vous nous
direz si vous aussi vous connaissez ces
intérimaires la nuit dans les urgences
en réanimation on verra cela enfin
bonsoir Frédéric bizard bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes économiste de la
santé professeur à l'ESCP et président
de l'Institut de santé agnès-sur-mer
c'est votre dossier également puisque
vous êtes en charge du personnel
soignant on attend votre regard
évidemment quand vous le souhaitez dans
ce débat on commence par planter le
décor que se passe-t-il dans les
hôpitaux et que se passe-t-il dans les
hôpitaux et que change précisément cette
loi il a deux secondes c'est le chrono
de Blacko
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir mon cher Stéphane
bonsoir à vous bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors je sais bien Myriam nous on est
une émission d'actualité on parle de ce
qui se passe là maintenant tout de suite
breaking news comme on dit dans notre
jargon d'ailleurs mais puisque vous y
tenez moi je veux bien faire un petit
point c'est vrai que les intérimaires
depuis qu'on aura mis un plafond là
depuis hier donc ils veulent plus aller
travailler à l'hôpital et en province où
on a besoin d'eux on s'inquiète
d'ailleurs ça fait la Une de l'après
vous allez voir ça fait la une pâte en
province le Parisien lui aussi fait la
une source au sujet ça fait la une dans
l'Est de la France l'union de Reims dans
l'ouest de la France Le Télégramme et
même au sud avec Corse-Matin cela dit
pour avoir étudié le dossier toute la
journée moi ce qui m'a surpris c'est pas
tellement là-dessus du truc en fait ça
fait c'est surtout que c'est ça fait
c'est pas nouveau ça fait 10 ans qu'on
tire le signal d'alarme sur ce sujet
donc je vous propose un petit flashback
nous allons voir il est assez long il
commence il y a 10 ans à l'époque il
était jeune il était socialiste il
s'appelle Olivier Véran et il avait fait
un rapport important de parlementaire
pour dire ça nous coûte 500 millions par
an à l'hôpital public faudrait faire un
truc sur les intérimaires bon pendant
trois ans son rapport reste dans un
tiroir mais en 2016 les socialistes sont
toujours au pouvoir et donc c'est la loi
Touraine sur l'hôpital on fixe un
plafond on ne paiera pas plus de 1170 €
brut pour 24 heures de garde on se dit
voilà le problème est réglé 4 ans plus
tard c'est le segment de la santé là on
est en 2020 et on se rend compte qu'en
fait la loi n'est tout simplement pas
appliquée donc au Ségur on se dit bah
oui faudrait quand même mettre fin à ce
fameux mercenariat de l'intérim médical
pour une fois ça traîne pas trop puisque
Stéphanie risque qui est avec nous qui
est médecin l'hôpital d'Orléans mais
aussi député du Loiret c'est donc une
proposition de loi dans laquelle bah on
force vraiment là mais en disant qu'il y
aura des poursuites donc ça on est en
2021 si on dépasse ce plafond vous dites
que c'est réglé non c'est pas réglé
parce qu'on se rend compte que si on
applique vraiment la loi et depuis et en
2021 Olivier on est plus député il est
devenu ministre de la santé il a fait
son chemin il fait marche arrière parce
qu'il se rend compte que ça risque
d'éloigner les intérimaires de l'hôpital
et on va se retrouver avec des gens des
hôpitaux ou il n'y a plus de médecins
donc résultat on est donc en 2023 10 ans
plus tard aujourd'hui ça coûte un
milliard un et demi par an à l'hôpital
donc 10 fois plus qu'il y a 10 ans et
donc François Brown se dit moi
j'aimerais bien une fois pour toute
qu'on mette en œuvre cette mesure et
vous allez voir qu'il est plutôt sympa
François Braun pour adoucir un peu la
pilule au lieu que ça soit à plafond
1170 euros brut il le passe à 1390 alors
je serai tenté de dire que quand les
pouvoirs publics pendant 10 ans veulent
installer une mesure ça serait peut-être
bien qu'on y arrive non je dis ça pour
le pays pour plus pour le crédit des
politiques si vous voulez d'ailleurs les
Fédération des hôpitaux ou les élus
locaux eux ben ils en ont carrément
marre ils disent non mais si c'est ça il
faut réquisitionner les intérimaires qui
ne veulent pas travailler donc je suis
désolé je voulais peut-être un peu
chargé la barque pour les intérimaires
parce que ce ne sont pas des cannibales
non ce ne sont pas des mercenaires ce
sont des êtres humains et en tant
qu'être humain Myriam si on vous
proposez de travailler moins pour gagner
plus ah ça c'est une proposition que
vous auriez prête à accepter bon il y a
peut-être un petit bémol dans le cas des
médecins puisque vous savez que ça ce
fameux serment d'Hippocrate où il est
marqué je ne me laisserai pas influencer
par la soif du gamin enfin on est
médecin est né en moins humain cela dit
une question avant de vous laisser
débattre est-ce que vraiment les
intérimaires font ça par appât du gain
ou est-ce que finalement il quitte
l'hôpital ils ne veulent plus être
titulaire simplement parce que l'hôpital
c'est devenu infernal trop d'heures pas
assez payé et donc mieux votre
intérimaire j'ai bien ce petit Stéphane
ce soir merci de nous avoir planté le
décor avec votre thon piquant comme
chaque soir Stefan et le risque je
commence avec vous non à l'intérim
cannibale dit François Braun on a
compris que c'est pas les les
intérimaires en tant que tel mais les
dérives qui sont visées par cette loi
est-ce qu'on a une idée déjà de la
proportion de ces dérives combien de
médecins intérimaires touchent jusqu'à
4000 5000 euros la garde de 24 heures à
l'hôpital non je crois que c'est très
important et ça a été dit dans
l'introduction c'est très important de
préciser que c'est pas l'ensemble des
médecins intérimaires la très grande
majorité rentre dans le plafond
actuellement proposé donc il existe
certains médecins intérimaires et je
veux pas jeter l'eau propre sur qui que
ce soit je veux dire le système
permettait de le faire et comme ça a été
très bien dit alors le recours aux
intérimaires a explosé quand même on le
voit avec la pandémie plus 69% entre
2019 et 2022 est-ce qu'on peut estimer
la part des intérimaires dans les
hôpitaux de France et surtout dans les
déserts médicaux on lit des chiffres 15
à 25% c'est énorme oui ça dépend
vraiment de la taille de l'hôpital de la
situation géographique de l'hôpital les
plus petits hôpitaux dans des situations
géographiques qui font peut-être moins
envie et bien il y a moins de monde donc
il y a plus d'intérimaires mais ce qu'on
voit surtout c'est la progression très
rapide et très importante et donc une
désorganisation des services et c'est ça
le la chose importante c'est à dire
quand vous avez le choix d'aller faire
de l'intérêt mais en quelques jours
gagner autant que si vous travaillez un
mois dans les services vous faites ça et
vous ça désorganise les services et du
coup il y a plus de projet de service il
y a plus de projets collectif pour
l'établissement et donc des malades qui
sont moins bien pris en charge on va y
venir dans le détail c'est vrai que les
dérives peuvent être un peu choquants
quand on connaît pas le dossier
professeur me garbane le manque de
médecin est-ce qu'il touche aussi des
les grands hôpitaux est-ce que vous avez
à Lariboisière des intérimaires dans
certains services et lesquels oui
malheureusement oui tout le monde sait
que nous manquons de soignants notamment
de médecins et notamment de certains
spécialistes et donc effectivement comme
ça a été dit
l'été pendant les vacances pendant les
jours fériés pendant les week-end la
nuit c'est-à-dire au cours des moments
les plus difficiles et bien les
titulaires ne peuvent plus travailler
parce qu'ils sont fatigués de leur
journée
parce que
il faut le reconnaître
la garde est très mal payée très mal
rémunéré pour un travail très intense et
bien les hôpitaux y compris
universitaires font appel à des
intérimaires certains étés j'ai connu
les blocs opératoires de l'hôpital de La
ribosère ne fonctionnait qu'avec des
intérimaires c'est-à-dire généralement
soit des médecins effectivement diplômés
français qui ne travaillent en intérim
soit parfois souvent des médecins
étrangers qui sont payés pendant cette
phase
au niveau d'un pH dernier échelon
praticien hospitalier
on a l'impression que voilà ça peut
monter très très haut alors ça montrait
où c'est possible
4000 euros la garde comme on a pu le
lire peut-être pas comme autant mais en
tout cas 2000 sans aucun problème
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement sinon
c'est
nous devons fermer le bloc opératoire
correspondant nous devons réduire une
ligne de garde donc on met les patients
en danger en fait c'est la continuité
des soins qui est menacé et donc
évidemment un directeur d'hôpital un
chef de service se doit de faire le
maximum pour pouvoir assurer la sécurité
des patients on va venir aux
conséquences dans un deuxième temps un
tout petit mot encore avec vous
professeurs l'ambiance dans un dans un
service quand il y a un intérimaire qui
est très bien payé est-ce que c'est un
peu délétère est-ce que il y en a un qui
est le passage il y en a un qui est
permanent ça se passe comme c'est
délétère par contre c'est souvent à mon
avis un mode d'exercice un peu solitaire
parce qu'effectivement généralement
c'est la nuit l'intérimaire est seul et
donc effectivement on va dire pour la
qualité des soins il vaut mieux
travailler en équipe connaître on va
dire le mode de fonctionnement du
service réfléchir s'imbiber et apprendre
souvent d'ailleurs on apprend comme vous
le savez évidemment on s'arrête pas à la
fin de ses études on apprend en continu
en travaillant et c'est au contact des
autres qu'on progresse et donc si
effectivement on est un peu à part et
bien je pense que malgré tout on va dire
l'intégration le raisonnement la qualité
est moindre mais à nouveau c'est soit ça
soit rien donc c'est pire c'est ça en
fait il y a une urgence des personnes
qui nous sauvent on a envie de vous
entendre et récré Boli docteur raybody
d'abord pourquoi vous avez choisi d'être
à 100 % intérimaire vacataire plutôt
qu'à plein temps dans un hôpital même
privé public ou privé pourquoi un titre
personnel j'ai subi et je dirais comme
beaucoup de mes collègues un burn out
dans mon activité précédente donc au
bout de 10 12 ans
j'irai d'une
c'est large j'irai dans un établissement
privé pendant plus de 10-12 ans on était
cinq associés on avait 35000 passages
par an autrement dit on avait 130 à 150
passages par jour on était de la journée
et à la nuit
vous imaginez un petit peu le rythme
vous avez dit j'arrête l'hôpital je
quitte
au contraire je gagnais très bien ma vie
et je peux vous assurer que mon banquier
n'a pas apprécié du tout que j'arrête
mon activité pendant un an j'ai eu aucun
revenu pour corriger mon burn out
j'étais en formation et ensuite
effectivement j'ai rattaqué des
remplacements je dirais parce que
effectivement quel choix on a en tant
que médecin qui tend l’hôpital ne
voulant pas y retourner où on va dans le
libéral où j'irai c'est le remplacement
il y a pas d'autres solutions en France
on nous propose pas d'autre choix le
remplacement pour bien comprendre c'est
vous qui faites un peu monter les
enchères comment est fixé la
rémunération vous allez voir le
directeur d'hôpital vous avez des
sociétés d'intérim comment ça se passe
concrètement on reçoit j'irai tous les
jours des dizaines pour pas dire des
centaines d'offres via plusieurs boîtes
d'intérim ou via les hôpitaux eux-mêmes
qui nous envoient leur manque et ils
nous offre un tarif à côté donc tout
simplement et vous croyez qu'on a le
temps de rappeler le directeur j'irai à
chaque fois pour négocier un tarif je
veux dire on ne le fait moi je l'ai
jamais fait de ma vie je veux dire
j'accepte ou pas vous acceptez vous pas
en fonction de l'offre et de la demande
parce que du tarif il y a tellement peu
d'action de l'activité de la
localisation en fonction vous savez il y
a deux ans pour exemple je suis j'en
avais ras-le-bol du couvre-feu au mois
de mars je suis parti 3 mois à
Martinique au CHU de France je peux vous
assurer que j'étais pas si bien payé que
ça pour aller au CHU en pleine période
covid mais j'y étais j'irai pour
découvrir l'île par exemple c'est un
exemple parmi l'autre mais 4000 euros
les 24 heures j'ai jamais eu ça de ma
vie jamais pas une seule fois
ce qui me choque c'est qu'on utilise des
cas comme ça j'irai par exemple ce Braun
cycle 6000 dans une entreprise privée
qui était une clinique sans donner de
preuve ni rien du tout sans aucun
chiffre et après on fait du bashing de
tous les médecins hier c'est ça mais
c'est une chasse aux sorcières plutôt
hier on traitait les généralistes de
fainéants maintenant on traite les
intérimaires de cannibale donc j'irai un
moment j'irai on peut plus accepter
comme ça je dirais décrébiliser
dévaloriser mépriser par je veux dire un
ministère de tutelle qui nous impose un
salaire qui nous impose des conditions
de travail qui sont désagréables au
quotidien on ne peut plus alors voilà
vous faites vraiment au ciel sourcils de
Madame la Ministre Agnès au Bodo comment
vous réagissez il y a des effets
d'aubaine on peut pas laisser dire que
le ministère de tutelle traite les
médecins généralistes de fainéants ou
les médecins intérimaires de cannibales
comme l'a rappelé Stéphanie East
l'intérêt mais nécessaire est utile à
l'hôpital il permet de remplacer des
postes vacants il permet d'assurer la
continuité des soins nous avons avec les
médecins généralistes et avec les
médecins traitants et les médecins
spécialistes une période d'échange à
aucun moment il n'a été dit que les
médecins généralistes étaient des
fainéants bien au contraire nous
reconnaissons l'engagement des
professionnels de santé et de tous les
professionnels de santé d'ailleurs
pour répondre aux besoins de santé de
nos concitoyens à un moment où on sait
très bien que nous avons un problème
démographique majeur et nous disons
c'est bien ensemble qu'on va réussir
je crois à arrêter cette spirale
négative et c'est aussi en parlant de
façon positive nous échangions tout à
l'heure docteur sur le fait que on voit
revenir des infirmières dans les
hôpitaux bah disons-le cette spirale
négative elle est en train de s'inverser
c'est bien ensemble que nous allons
réussir à répondre aux besoins de santé
de nos concitoyens est-ce que vous
pensez vraiment quand on n'est pas
parvenu sur l'intérim qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire que cette fois-ci en mettant ce
plafond là et bien la loi sera respectée
parce que comme on le sait il y a
tellement tellement de besoins de
médecins que les directeurs d'hôpitaux
sont obligés et bien dans l'employer
pour garantir l'accès aux soins en
j'entends ce que dit Monsieur Evoli sur
une espèce de volonté partagée de se
dire que
la relation au travail et la changer
elle a profondément changé et que
peut-être nos systèmes hospitalier que
peut-être notre système de santé n'a pas
su s'adapter assez vite à cette volonté
d'aller du public au privé du salariat
au libéral de travailler plus à mi-temps
c'est ce cas souhaité annoncer le
président de la République lorsqu'il dit
qu'on va redonner au service
l'organisation et une espèce d'autonomie
d'organisation mais pour ça il nous faut
bien des équipes qui soient là
structurés et de façon permanente donc
l'intérim ne peut être qu'une solution
j'allais dire de remplacement et
transitoire la loi elle a dit quelque
chose en deux temps en 2016 elle fixe un
plafond c'est la loi qui fixe un plafond
la loi qui a porté Stéphane iris elle
permet au directeur d'Ars et aux
occasions de santé
d'aller vérifier que cette loi elle est
bien respectée je crois que la loi
allait faite pour être respectée et avec
François brode nous avons décidé qu'il
était important et urgent de faire
respecter la loi nous avons aussi
profiter de ce que le tarif était fixé
en 2016 de le réévaluer et de mettre le
plafond à 1390 euros brut par jour parce
que là aussi nous devons assurer entre
les professionnels qui travaillent dans
le même service de se dire que un
professionnel qui vient travailler une
journée gagnerait 1390 euros par jour
alors que le même professionnel
gagnerait ça on peut en plusieurs en
plusieurs c'est pas c'est pas acceptable
et il y avait des dérives choquantes de
le fait de lutter contre ces dérives
pour réorganiser le travail à l'échelle
des services alors Frédéric bizard
j'aimerais votre avis on va parler des
conséquences concrètes parce qu'on voit
déjà et on a reportage à Issoudun dans
un instant je vais vous le montrer qui a
dû fermer son service de gériatrie au
moins temporairement donc il y a déjà
des conséquences lourdes sur le fait
qu'il y ait des dérives dans l'intérim à
l'hôpital est-ce que vous confirmez et
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut être
efficace
je pense qu'on fait pas une politique à
partir des beaucoup de cas particuliers
donc il y a deux façons de voir cette
affaire soit on considère que c'est une
affaire transitoire où il y a quelques
dérives et il suffit qu'on mette un
plafond et puis les choses iront mieux
et que les racines du mal sont pas sont
pas ailleurs bon c'est ce que j'entends
beaucoup ce soir et ce truc moi je crois
pas ça je crois que c'est juste le
symptôme d'un malaise très profond de
notre système de santé en général et du
système hospitalier en particulier vous
savez quand les les praticiens
hospitaliers décident d'aller dans les
médecins décident d'aller dans la
fonction publique
l'attitude mercenaire est pas vraiment
le
l'attitude centrale qu'on demande à
quelqu'un qui va dans une dans une
fonction publique qui est plutôt quelque
chose d'assez encadré ou si on veut
vraiment quelque chose de beaucoup plus
libre on va dans l'exercice libéral on
va donner la fonction publique donc je
pense pas que ces professionnels de
santé soient s'ils n'en sont pas forcés
des gens qui vont véritablement avoir
une aspiration à gagner un maximum et à
utiliser tous les tous les moyens qu'il
qu'on les a jetés pour vous d'abord vous
l'avez dit vous-même ce phénomène c'est
pas la responsabilité de ceux qui sont
au pouvoir maintenant je comprends que
quand on est parlementaire on est en
responsabilité on essaie de trouver des
solutions mais je crains que le remède
risque d'être pire que la malle donc la
cause elle est profonde elle date d'il y
a une vingtaine d'années où on a changé
complètement le paradigme de la santé où
on est passé à une approche qui était
relativement médicale relativement
social à une approche purement
technocratico comptable c'est-à-dire
qu'on considère deux choses on considère
que la santé est un coût et qu'il faut
réduire ce coût et la deuxième chose
c'est qu'on considère que les médecins
doivent être sous la tutelle de la
techno structure et sous une tutelle
plutôt stricte puisque les médecins dans
un hôpital comme dans un territoire sont
devenus globalement des pions ils n'ont
plus aucune
aux Hospitaliers c'est bien pour ça
qu'il y a une perte de sens du métier de
médecin qui fait que finalement le
médecin se dit puisque je n'ai pas
d'action possible sur l'organisation du
système et bien je vais maximiser mon
intérêt personnel et donc on voit qu'on
est passé de 6000 à 12000 ça fait quand
même un tiers de la force vive des
praticiens hospitalières
plus 20% de contractuels vous avez plus
de 50% de des médecins qui sont
particulaires il est évident qu'on peut
comprendre le malaise à l'hôpital
lorsqu'on a cette histoire
technique dessus donc dès que je l'ai je
vous le diffuse on va venir sur les
conséquences déjà quand même les dérives
parce que on comprend que peut-être on
prend le problème à l'envers il y a une
énorme crise à l'hôpital on y vient mais
il y a des dérives réellement sur les
salaires ou pas
vous en avez vu vous ou pas moi
personnellement non dans le service de
réanimation nous ne faisons pas appel
aux intérimaires médecins par contre
nous avons eu notamment pendant la crise
covid des intérimaires infirmiers
effectivement c'est un mode d'exercice
qui a ses avantages c'est-à-dire une
certaine liberté un certain choix de ses
heures de travail
l'absence de contrainte d'une autorité
médicale ou administrative et puis des
offres d'emploi
énormes avec des possibilités de voyage
de découverte de nouveaux services donc
il y a beaucoup d'avantages c'est vrai
qu'il y a aussi des inconvénients c'est
à dire qu'effectivement en termes de on
va dire d'intégration dans une équipe de
formation médicale continue
peut-être de suivi d'un patient en
réanimation quand vous êtes suivi par un
médecin différent tous les jours et bien
la qualité de la prise en charge la
stratégie diagnostic et thérapeutique
n'est pas la même que si vous avez le
même médecin qui vous connaît depuis
votre entrée qui vous suit
bienvenus c'est ça pour vous je dirais
en théorie oui maintenant effectivement
il faut pas que cette décision empire
les difficultés parce que
malheureusement si nos collègues
intérimaires partaient du système
hospitalier c'est le système de soins
entiers qui va s'effondrer donc
aujourd'hui l'hôpital public
en très grande difficulté on va dire
dans les grandes villes ça peut encore
aller mais certains hôpitaux parce qu'on
disait 20% des des médecins sont
hospitaliers sont des intérimaires mais
dans certaines petites structures c'est
pas loin de 100%, c'est pas mal de 100%
Bastia Alès Nogent-le-Rotrou
Bry-sur-Marne la maternité de Sarlat qui
apparemment est menacé stéphanieriste
les conséquences elles sont terribles et
c'est tout de suite manifestement les
services qui sont menacés et qui sont
même parfois fermées temporairement il y
a deux points je crois un il faut rester
humble sur ce sujet on sait qu'on a
beaucoup d'établissements qui sont
fragiles pas en raison de cette loi mais
en raison de la démographie médicale qui
est très faible et qui entraîne du coup
depuis hier qui ferme non dans ma région
des services sont fermés hier la
maternité de Sarlat c'était déjà avant
nombre de gériables c'est dans ma région
je vois très bien
vous avez raison que cette loi va
peut-être accélérer certains services
qui auraient dû fermer dans les semaines
qui viennent je n'en sais rien je ne
l'espère pas
ce qui a été mis en place et ce qui a
nécessité la préparation de la mise en
place de cette loi depuis 2021 en fait
c'est de faire une cartographie de
repérer les endroits qui étaient les
plus fragiles de pouvoir aussi proposer
des contrats des contrats à ces
intérimaires qui dans la majorité des
cas
accepte ces contrats donc je ne suis pas
sûr que le grand soir annonçait arrive
maintenant je crois qu'il faut rester
humble parce que nous avons un problème
de médical nous avons d'ailleurs arrêté
le numerus clausus pour augmenter le
nombre de médecins formés mais vous
savez ça prend 10 ans oui mais donc la
cause de ces difficultés elle vient bien
de la démographie médicale donc on s'en
est
occupé dès qu'on est arrivé et de la
question de l'installation des médecins
aussi je ne peux plus dans les services
fermeront ce qui est sûr et ce qu'on
voyait c'est que dans ma région des
services sont fermés alors que le
plafond atteignait largement assez
régulièrement des chiffres beaucoup plus
haut que ce que a dit Monsieur donc on
voit bien que soit on continue cette
augmentation exponentielle des tarifs
qui permettent pas pour certains
services d'ailleurs de persister
puisqu'il y avait des fermetures avant
la mise en place de cette loi soit on
dit à un moment donné récupérer des
médecins pour aller à l'hôpital
travaillons sur les sujets moi je suis
d'accord avec Monsieur bizarre je veux
dire le sujet de l'attractivité de
l'hôpital et au centre d'ailleurs le
résidence et engagée à tout le monde en
convient il fallait retravailler sur le
financement des établissements sur la
rémunération des professionnels donc ce
travail là il est il prend du temps et
parfois il peut y avoir des effets
boomerang avec des décisions de court
terme comme celle-là est Boli les
conséquences c'est pas vous qui allez me
contredire elles vont elles vont être
quoi
directement sur le terrain dans les
services ça fait des semaines qu'on le
dit les conséquences seront désastreuses
pour la santé des Français j'aimerais
revenir juste une minute sur le terme
dérive on part d'un postulat qu'il y a
une dérive aucun chiffre du gouvernement
pour nous dire combien il y a de dérive
est-ce que des quatre ou 6000 euros il y
en a pour 20%
dans lesquels même anonyme les
intérimaires témoignent un salaire à un
million de la garde mais ce sont des
discussions de comptoir quelques cas
aucune étude n'a été faite de même qui a
aucune étude d'impact sur la réalisation
et la mise en place de cette loi et
aujourd'hui on le voit je veux dire moi
je pourrais vous dire qu'il y a plus de
pédiatrie à Pontivy a doué la nuit on a
plus non plus que à donna le cardiologue
qui était remplaçant depuis trois ans à
démissionner hier où je remplaçant je
pourrais vous citer à Bastia où il y a
plus de soins d'intensif ou à chaque
fois ce sont plutôt les déserts médicaux
qui souffrent le plus désert médicaux
non mais c'est des plus petits hôpitaux
près de 200 services risqueraient d'être
perturbé voire de fermer 200 services
c'est le c'est le patient c'est lui qui
à court terme va avoir un risque de
perte de chance va avoir une dégradation
de son service à partir du moment où il
y a des fermetures alors certains disent
d'ailleurs que tout ça est provoqué pour
bon mais on va pas rentrer dans cette
paranoïa moi quand même juste revenir
sur une chose parce que oui on parle
beaucoup des dépassements des abus et
autres mais c'est d'abord l'échec de
l'État cette affaire d'échec de l'État
depuis une vingtaine d'années
ce sont pas les professionnels de santé
qui sont responsables de la dégradation
des conditions de travail constatées par
tous les professionnels qui soient
médecins ou paramédicaux enfin je pense
qu'il faut être un peu raisonnable je
pense pas que ça soit et je je pense que
l'intérim a petit échelle est nécessaire
l'intérim à grande échelle c'est un
poison donc je défends absolument pas
c'est un peu de Français
l'intérim mais je veux dire que
l'intérim est la conséquence des
politiques menées depuis des années qui
les professeurs de santé sont les
premiers à le constater mais aussi les
patients maintenant ben conduisent quand
même à une catastrophe en matière
d'attractivité l'hôpital est devenu un
lieu peu attractif pour les soignants et
un lieu dangereux pour les patients
c'est un fait bon donc moi je veux bien
qu'on discute du sexe des anges en
disant ah mais lui j'ai entendu que il y
a eu deux abus de 4000 de 4000 euros
vous savez 1300 1390 euros moi je sais
pas comment en économie on est très
méfiant quand le politique comme ça fixe
arbitrairement des tarifs des prix tout
ça je sais pas à quoi ça correspond ça
correspond à peu près à trois fois le
salaire moyen pendant les pays de l'OCDE
et les médecins sont plutôt payé 4 à 5
fois en moyenne et sachant quand vous
êtes un intérimaire vous n'avez aucune
protection par rapport à ce qui est le
cas dans les salariés les directeurs
d'hôpitaux malgré les menaces de
poursuivre malgré les contrôles cette
fois-ci vont appliquer ou pas le choix
et continueront ce que tu arrives un peu
dans le mode de sanction c'est comment
est-ce qu'on les sanctionne parce que je
rappelle que un médecin
contracte un contrat avec un
établissement avec le donc il faut que
l'établissement soit d'accord oui mais
c'est bien il y a une responsabilité
bi-partite dans la faire bon et
finalement on pourrait penser on
pourrait faire confiance aux directions
d'établissement pour respecter la loi
mais en fait étonnamment on fait pas
confiance déjà on fait pas confiance on
va essayer je sentais mais on fait pas
confiance aux directions puisque l'on
dit
elle ne l'est pas parce que les étapes
parce que les directions d'établissement
n'ont pas le choix ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que là on voit ce
centralisme technocratique c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait toutes les décisions sont
prises à l'échelle des ARS ou à
l'échelle du ministère on ne fait aucune
confiance aux établissements par contre
dans tous les discours vous entendez
autonomie autonomie des hôpitaux cette
question des établissements et des
professionnels de santé dans le cadre du
Ségur c'était la mesure 3 c'est-à-dire
que c'est les professionnels les
directeurs d'établissement les
représentants syndicaux qui ont demandé
qu'on l'inscrivent dans la loi et qu'on
fasse en sorte que cette mesure qui
était inscrite dans la loi Touraine soit
appliquée c'est une demande vraiment des
professionnels c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
repris dans le cadre de ma loi qui
reprenait les mesures du cirque
d'hypocrisie
Firmin le Bodo je sais pas s'il faut
parler du sexe des gens vous remettre
l'église au coeur du village comme vient
de le faire Stéphanie c'est cette mesure
elle était demandée par les
professionnels pas les directeurs
d'hôpitaux la loi a été votée ce que
nous faisons depuis hier c'est juste une
application de la loi nous sommes
d'accord pour dire que nous avons besoin
de l'intérim c'est un fait vous avez ok
monsieur bizarre la situation de
l'hôpital très clairement avec le
ministre la demande du Président de la
République et la première ministre nous
avons lancé les chantiers pour ref pas
que l'hôpital le système de santé parce
que si nous le refons donc que l'hôpital
sans travailler sur la ville on va se
retrouver dans la même situation donc
l'idée c'est bien de travailler sur nos
deux jambes du système de santé c'est à
dire à la fois la ville mais aussi à la
fois de l'hôpital et les premiers enjeux
c'est bien sûr de travailler sur la
réforme de la tarification mais aussi et
je le redis parce que c'est une demande
sur les conditions de travail des
professionnels c'est de rendre cette
espèce d'autonomie des services parce
que c'est bien à l'échelle du service
qu'on va pouvoir se réorganiser se
réorganiser avec ce que Monsieur Ray
bolidi sur la volonté des professionnels
de s'adapter à cette nouvelle relation
de qualité de vie au travail et de
qualité personnelle d'organisation c'est
bien ça qu'il nous faut retravailler et
cette autonomie c'est pas une vue de
l'esprit c'est une volonté et c'est ce
vers quoi les directeurs d'hôpitaux vont
aller on voit bien que le grand sujet
c'est la crise de l'hôpital le court
terme quand même parce que le cabinet de
François Braun dit aujourd'hui aucun
patient ne sera laissé
solution hier il a dit qu'il y aurait
aucun service de fermer je dirais
aujourd'hui on voit ce que ça donne en
France les ARS les agences régionales de
santé vont essayer de d'identifier
toutes les situations
de dépassement ça va pas changer depuis
tout à l'heure vous ne dites il y a pas
de gens qui sont payés beaucoup plus que
le plafond donc ça va pas il y a une
question de respect je pense que vous
allez oublier cette notion-là me dire ça
fait ça fait des semaines je dirais
qu'on est on est insulté tous les jours
je suis quand même on dit qu'on a besoin
des intérimaires oui j'ai bien compris
qu'on a besoin des intérimaires mais on
veut pas les payer comme l'hôpital
un système de fonctionnement
je suis choqué si ça existe parce qu'on
ne l'a jamais proposé et mon collègue
n'a jamais vu non plus te dire nous sur
le terrain on le connaît pas vous
comprenez il y a simplement des
ministres qui nous disent oh mon dieu je
veux dire ça a été payé le problème une
fois qu'il y a pas de problème
c'est que à l'hôpital on ne paye ni les
pas d'huile médecin étranger à 17 euros
de l'heure ni les internes à 12 euros de
l'heure par contre là on va augmenter de
7% la facture je dirais de tous les
patients pour économiser et combien
c'est 4 à 5 milliards de plus qu'on veut
récupérer si on veut des dérives par an
oui donc voilà chercher des dérives que
les politiques cherchent aussi des
dérives du côté des consultants je veux
dire 2 milliards 5 en 2021 de dépenser
de ce côté-là et nous qui faisons un
travail de terrain je veux dire on parle
de désert médical médicaux d'accord je
veux dire mais les intérimaires vont
partout dans tous les coins de la France
soutenir des hôpitaux de proximité qui
seraient fermés depuis des années sinon
je veux dire on bouche les trous c'est
dit professeur megaban la suite c'est
évidemment la crise de l'hôpital il y a
eu le Ségur manifestement ça n'a pas
suffi il y a les conditions de travail
qui sont très importantes on le voit
bien puisque les intérimaires font ce
travail que d'autres ne peuvent plus
faire qu'est-ce que vous vous attendez
concrètement pour terminer ce débat bah
écoutez moi j'attends on va dire une
modification vraiment de la gouvernance
de l'hôpital public une simplification
de la technostructure qui nous gouverne
cette fameuse autonomie du service que
l'on voit toujours pas sur le terrain
les modalités de financement de
l'hôpital n'ont pas changé les pôles et
les démus sont toujours présents
contrairement à ce que les médecins
souhaitent on va dire en pratique pour
le moment les choses n'ont pas changé
alors je sais que il faut du temps pour
instruire une loi et pour réfléchir à
l'avenir mais aujourd'hui rien n'a
changé en pratique et malheureusement la
trajectoire de l'hôpital public continue
à aller vers le bas même si un petit
espoir avec le retour des infirmiers
bien on va s'arrêter sur cette petite
note d'espoir merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu débattre et désolé et
surtout pour notre reporter Clément
Perwez qui avait fait à l'aller-retour à
Issoudun il y a eu un problème
malencontre technique qui n'a pas mis pu
voilà nous permettre de vous montrer son
reportage bien dommage merci à vous
merci d'être venu débattre vous restez
avec moi une experiment le Baudot dans
une dizaine de minutes exactement les
parties pris de nos affranchis vous les
voyez ce soir le regard européen de
Richard Werly sur la tournée Quentin
demain Emmanuel Macron en Chine le
social avec Fanny guide Michel sur la
nouvelle patronne de la CGT j'ai nommé
Sophie Binet et puis l'agenda hyper
chargé de la nu pour aujourd'hui entre
l'Élysée et le Conseil constitutionnel
ce sera dans Bourbon express avec Marco
pommier mais d'abord madame les
ministres on va parler fin de vie la
convention citoyenne a donc remis son
rapport hier au Président il est temps
de faire évoluer la loi c'est le
président lui-même qui le dit vous avez
donc trois mois c'est peu 3 mois pour la
construire cette loi mais comme on va le
voir dans l'invitation de Marion Becker
vous y avez beaucoup beaucoup réfléchi
regardez
si on vous invite
Agnès Firmin le Beaudeau c'est parce que
le Président vous a choisi en tant que
ministre délégué et chargé de
l'organisation territoriale des
professionnels de santé pour superviser
une partie des concertations sur la fin
de vie vous avez orchestré les
rencontres avec les médecins les
patients les soignants et les
parlementaires vous avez également
entrepris un marathon auprès de nos
voisins européens mais aussi dans
l'Orégon en quête du meilleur modèle
vous avez étudié leur pratique en
matière de soins palliatifs et de
suicides assister car Emmanuel Macron
l'a annoncé hier après les conclusions
de la convention citoyenne il attend du
gouvernement un projet de loi d'ici
l'été nous pourrons ainsi à travers
cette maturation permettre je le
souhaite je le crois
de tracer un nouveau jalon vers ce
modèle français de la fin de vie
vous préparez donc Agnès Firmin le Bodo
cet échéance il faut dire que vous
connaissez bien le milieu médical
pharmacies à nos Havre femme de médecin
vous devenez en 2017 député de
Seine-Maritime puis votre nom et soufflé
par votre ami Édouard Philippe au
Président vous devenez ministre délégué
à l'Assemblée vous avez été présidente
de la commission spéciale chargée
d'étudier le projet de loi bioéthique
puis vous avez soutenu la proposition de
loi d'Olivier fallorni pour une fin de
vie libre et choisie un engagement qui
vous a été reproché j'ai un avis
personnel cet avis ne concerne que moi
et j'ai bien l'intention de travailler
de façon très neutre sur ce sujet qui
concerne qui est un vrai débat de
société où chacun a un rapport intime
vous-même avez été intimement confronté
au tabou et au cas de conscience en 2013
votre mère attendent d'un cancer du
pancréas après s'être battu deux ans
arrive au bout de ses chimiothérapies
elle se sait condamnée vous demande la
piqûre afin d'abréger ses souffrances
vous lui répondez que vous n'avez pas le
droit
alors on a une question pour vous Agnès
Firmin le Baudot si vous en aviez eu le
droit qu'auriez-vous fait
[Musique]
mon mari a répondu à cette question mais
en tout cas ma réponse a été me dire on
l'a accompagné et cet accompagnement
d'une semaine a été profitable pour qui
je pense qu'il a été plus profitable
pour nous
que pour elle faut beaucoup d'humilité
il faut beaucoup d'humanité pour se
forger une conviction sur le sujet on
voit qu'il y a les épreuves personnelles
qu'on traverse mais la loi elle va être
générale elle ne peut pas être issue des
cas particuliers comment on arrive à une
forme peut-être pas de consensus qui
n'est peut-être pas possible mais à
dégager ce modèle français de fin de vie
qui a appelé le chef de l'État en tout
cas je veux dire que l'exercice qui a
été le mien depuis le mois de septembre
a été complètement différent de celui
que j'ai pu mener lorsque j'étais
parlementaire lorsqu'on n'est
parlementaire on travaille sur un texte
de loi on nous demande de répondre oui
non ou abstention là le président de la
République avait confié une mission à
deux ministres à Olivier Véran et à
moi-même de travailler sur ce sujet
son texte de loi puisque nous ne savions
pas avant hier qu'il y aurait un texte
de loi donc j'ai fait le travail de
consultation d'écoute d'échanges
vraiment j'ai beaucoup écouté j'ai
beaucoup allé voir de soignants vous
avez beaucoup voyagé aussi jusqu'en
Oregon aux États-Unis pour comprendre
vraiment comment les pays avaient évolué
pourquoi il n'avait pas évolué
d'ailleurs comme la Grande-Bretagne et
ce travail je l'ai fait en faisant
complètement abstraction de ce que
j'avais fait en avril 2021 parce que je
pense que sur ce sujet
nous devons ouvrir un nouveau droit à
titre personnel je n'ai aucune certitude
sur ce que je ferais si je devais un
jour
répondre à cette question je zéro
certitude un nouveau droit déjà le mot
est important c'est un droit pour les
malades qui évidemment sous conditions
très strictes demande cette aide active
à mourir soit le suicide assisté ou
l'assistance au suicide soit le tanasie
et là il faut un tiers en général un
médecin qui fait le geste létal y a-t-il
un modèle qui vous semble plus proche de
ce que pourrait être le modèle français
très clairement je ne vais pas répondre
à votre question puisque
la volonté du Président de la République
est sous l'autorité de la première
ministre nous allons travailler à
co-construire cette loi ça veut dire
quoi co-construit cette loi ça veut dire
travailler bien sûr avec les
parlementaires qui faisaient partie des
gens dans les travaux que j'ai mené
depuis le mois de septembre mais aussi
avec les soignants et je pense que nous
devons trouver ce modèle
le président de la République a appelé à
la française qui nous permettent de
rendre effectif ce nouveau droit avec
les lignes rouges fixées par le
Président de la République qui sont les
lignes rouges que les citoyens ont
eux-mêmes ont même mis le discerne la
volonté
à l'épreuve d'une souffrance incurable
et insupportable et un choix libre
éclairé et réitérer vous les avez
écoutez suivi aux ces œufs c'est 184
citoyens tirés au sort qu'est-ce qui
vous a le plus marqué dans ce travail de
démocratie moi je suis allée les voir
plusieurs fois j'ai été impressionné
vraiment et je le dis vraiment très
sincèrement j'étais pas spécialement au
départ une adepte de ce genre de
convention citoyenne je pense que nous
avons trouvé là et le président de la
République est le président du CESU de
Thierry baudet ont dit que ce système
était arrivé à maturité je pense qu'à
travers les débats qui ont été menés sur
ce sujet de société ses citoyens
engagé ils ont été du début à la fin
présent ils ont beaucoup travaillé
beaucoup d'entre eux en savent beaucoup
beaucoup plus que certains d'entre nous
sur le sujet ils ont vraiment beaucoup
travaillé et ce qui va impressionner
c'est dans la capacité d'écoute tout ça
dans un profond respect à chaque fois
que je suis allé les voir ils avaient
toujours des questions moi je les ai vu
échanger pendant 20-25 minutes sur la
place du mot ou ou du mot et quel était
l'incidence si on mettait où et j'ai
trouvé ça assez extraordinaire
c'était j'ai trouvé ce débat passionnant
extraordinaire et tout ça dans un
profond respect 75% des citoyens ont
souhaité que la loi évolue 25% de non
mais les citoyens minoritaires ont aussi
continué à participer aux échanges tout
en étant écouté et à se disant moi je ne
souhaite pas mais si elle devait évoluer
peut-être ce modèle là serait mieux
que l'autre c'est j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment impressionnant on peut y
arriver d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de
voir que les résultats des
préconisations coïncident plus ou moins
d'ailleurs avec l'opinion des Français
70% selon le dernier sondage rassurant
alors c'est plutôt rassurant puisque
c'est une représentait le panel de nos
concitoyens de la France les oppositions
à l'euthanasie restent quand même très
fortes particulièrement celle d'une
partie du corps médical l'ordre des
médecins ne veut pas qu'un des leurs
puissent participer à un processus qui
mènerait à une euthanasie est-ce que
vous les comprenez en j'entends et le
débat que nous avons eu juste avant sur
l'état du système de santé en France
j'entends que les certains médecins pas
tous souhaitent que nous n'allions pas
jusqu'à l'euthanasie je pense que là
elle se travaille de co-construction il
va se faire avec les soignants j'ai
beaucoup travaillé depuis le mois de
septembre avec les acteurs des soins
palliatifs dont la grande majorité ne
souhaite pas ne souhaitait pas que la
loi évolue était française
d'accompagnement soins palliatifs et
particulièrement hostile à toute
évolution de la loi pourquoi on entend
si peu les autres médecins qui eux sont
prêts à faire ce geste il en existe
certains ont aussi fait des tribunes
faut qu'il s'expriment c'est un peu
c'est important aussi qui puisse nous
accompagner mais dans le groupe de
soignants que j'avais constitué il y
avait des soignants qui étaient opposés
mais aussi des oignons qui étaient
favorables et quand je parle des
soignants il ne faut pas parler que des
médecins je pense qu'il est important
aussi de prendre en compte la parole à
la fois des infirmières mais aussi des
aides-soignantes qui sont le plus
longtemps au chevet des patients mais le
président de la République il nous a
demandé bien plus qu'un projet de loi
sur une aide active à mourir le
président de la République il nous a
demandé d'avancer très fort sur les
soins palliatifs parce que là il y a une
unanimité pour dire qu'il faut avancer
sur les soins palliatifs mais il nous a
aussi une égalité d'accès territoire des
enjeux majeurs sur le domicile sur les
EHPAD sur les établissements qui
accueillent des personnes en situation
de handicap peut-être un champ que nous
n'avions pas encore beaucoup exploré sur
les soins palliatifs pédiatriques là
aussi il y a une loi décennale la t-il
dit sur les soins Palli franchement
quand on voit la crise de l'hôpital on
se dit mais veut pieux on y arrivera pas
mais si on va y arriver on va y arriver
parce qu'il y a une volonté partagée
d'abord à construire des solutions à
former des médecins c'est pas c'est pas
qu'un question de moyens c'est parce
qu'il a pas de professionnel formé donc
formons des médecins travaillons
ensemble avec l'hospitalisation à
domicile et sinon trouver ensemble les
solutions pour répondre aux besoins de
nos concitoyens et le président de la
République hier il nous a dit de
construire un modèle d'accompagnement de
la fin de vie et dans ce mot
accompagnement de la fin de vie il y a
bien sûr une aide active à mourir à
construire des soins palliatifs à
développer mais aussi à réfléchir à ceux
qui j'allais dire nous unit tous
travailler sur l'accompagnement du deuil
chose que nous n'avons pas vraiment
encore fait et pourtant il y a des
belles choses à développer sur
l'accompagnement des aidants à la fin de
vie et puis peut-être se poser la
question sur un retour sur le covid
est-ce qu'il faut créer un droit
opposable à la visite en EHPAD ou à
l'hôpital pour ne pas nous retrouver
dans des situations qui nous ont tous
ébranlés sur le plan sur le plan humain
certains de nos concitoyens sont décédés
tout seul la clause de conscience elle
sera garantie à tous les soignants qui
refuseraient de faire le geste si
l'euthanasie était légalisé bien sûr à
titre personnel je crois qu'elle la
cause de conscience sur ces sujets elle
est importante je ne vais pas préempté
de ce que diront les personnes qui
participeront sous l'autorité de la
première ministre à la construction de
la loi la cause de conscience elle a été
nécessaire lorsque l'IVG a été légalisé
lorsque l'article 1 de la PPL va falloir
y avait été voté la cause de conscience
était déjà dans les parties je crois que
c'est important de pouvoir assurer cette
cause de conscience si jamais nous
allions vers un système euthanasie d'un
mot pour terminer les prochaines étapes
donc qui va tenir la plume pour rédiger
le futur projet de loi c'est vous c'est
je ne sais pas
le prix le président de la République de
la République a demandé à au
gouvernement donc la première ministre
va dans les prochains jours j'imagine
consulter pour savoir qui portera ce
texte de loi l'important c'est que texte
de loin il soit une oeuvre collective
qu'il soit co-construit pour que nous
puissions nous le souhaitons présenter
avant l'été avant l'été discuter à
l'Assemblée discuter à l'Assemblée fin
2023 2024 fin 2023 nous puissions avoir
puisqu'il sera présenté à l'été que fin
203 on puisse au moins à l'Assemblée
nationale avoir fait une première
lecture de ce texte c'est un texte
attendu par un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens c'est un texte qui doit nous
permettre d'ouvrir un nouveau droit mais
qui doit aussi peut-être et je le
souhaite vous réconcilier avec cet
esprit démocratique et nos concitoyens
nous ont ouvert la voie soyons en ligne
merci beaucoup évidemment vous êtes la
bienvenue pour nous présenter ce texte
si vous le portez dans l'hémicy gagné
faire mal au Bodo restez avec nous c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos affranchis pour
terminer cette émission ils vont vous
faire réagir leur parti pris tout de
suite
bienvenue à vous les affranchis Fanny
guinochet de France Info qui va nous
parler actualités sociales Richard Werly
du quotidien suisse alémanique Blic qui
nous parle de Chine tout à l'heure mais
aussi d'Europe mais on commence comme
chaque soir par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est raconté ce soir par Marco pommier
bonsoir Marco bonsoir Myriam ce soir je
vous raconte l'histoire du logo encore
et toujours mobilisée contre la réforme
des retraites journée hyper chargées
pour la nupes ce mardi acte 1 ce matin
quelques parlementaires ont été reçus à
l'Elysée par le directeur de cabinet
d'Emmanuel Macron objectif remettre une
lettre au chef de l'État réclamant
l'annulation de la réforme des retraites
Marco alors j'ai regardé les images il y
avait des communistes mais où était les
autres alliés de la nupesse il n'était
pas là ça ne vous a pas échappé Myriam à
nous non plus ce matin dans la
délégation il y avait des députés et des
sénateurs essentiellement communistes en
revanche pas de socialiste ni
d'écologistes ou même d'insoumis de quoi
un peu agacer André Chassagne
pourquoi les autres groupes de la nuit
pèse vous accompagnent pas aujourd'hui
il faut leur poser la question dans un
premier temps ils étaient favorables à
notre démarche nous avons même changé la
formule à la demande des socialistes qui
ne souhaitaient pas qu'il y a un défilé
qui est un cortège il nous en dit il
faut en rassemblement donc on a opté
pour rassemblement aucune explication ne
m'a été donné
jusqu'à hier soir tous les espoirs
étaient permis vous êtes déçu du coup je
suis pas déçu je regrette
voilà un des regrets alors que dans le
plan initial il devait être 150
parlementaires de gauche à traverser la
scène pour exiger d'être reçu par
Emmanuel Macron l'image devait faire le
buzz sauf que sauf que et bien les
socialistes et les écologistes n'étaient
pas du tout emballés résultat bah ce
matin il y a des pas d'image de
rassemblement devant l'Élysée toute
forme de marchand côté l'Elysée ça dit
vite forcément en revanche unité cet
après-midi de la nupesse au Conseil
constitutionnel oui c'était l'acte 2 de
cette journée un grand oral devant les
sages de la rue de Montpensier pendant
une heure une délégation de la coalition
de la gauche a défendu son recours
contre la réforme des retraites la
gauche appelée d pour une censure totale
du texte du Gouvernement plusieurs axes
d'attaque d'abord le véhicule législatif
utilisé par le gouvernement pour cette
réforme contraire à plusieurs
dispositions constitutionnelles d'après
la gauche la nupes à qui pointent du
doigt aussi la réduction drastique du
temps des débats ou encore l'insenséité
des informations transmises au Parlement
pour légiférer bref ça ne manque pas
d'arguments écoutez Mathilde panot
Mathilde panot est-ce que ce recours au
Conseil constitutionnel il a vraiment
des chances d'aboutir selon vous très
franchement alors oui d'abord parce que
ça s'est déjà vu dans l'histoire une
censure totale d'un texte on avait eu ça
le 24 décembre 1979 où le Conseil
constitutionnel avait censuré l'ensemble
d'un texte budgétaire du budget et ça
s'est déjà vu aussi en 2012 pour des
problèmes de sincérité et de clarté des
débats alors une loi tout entière elle
aussi avait été censurée ensuite si par
hasard nous perdions bon on verra déjà
moi j'attends de voir avant de et bien
je crois que il faut se rappeler
toujours que les gens sont dans la rue
non pas parce que la loi est
inconstitutionnelle mais parce qu'elle
est injuste
voilà fin du suspense Myriam vous le
savez vendredi 14 avril ce jour-là et
bien le Conseil constitutionnel rendra
sa décision sur le recours mais aussi
sur la procédure de référendum
d'initiative partagée le fameux RIP a
d'ici là et bien la coalition de la
gauche va pouvoir se parler c'est l'acte
3 de cette journée ça se passe ce soir
avec un séminaire de la nupes
post-examen réforme des retraites on
imagine que certains auront besoin de
vider leur sac ah ça c'est sûr Agnes
ont la durée vous y croyez où il y a des
débuts de fissures qui montrent qu'elle
va éclater on voit bien que tout le
monde n'était pas présent pour aller
vers l'Elysée je suis surprise de voir
Charles de Courson dans la gauche vous
êtes sûr de vous il était dans le groupe
yote mais il était également présent
c'était juste pour dire que ah oui il
s'est légèrement comme on dit
je voulais je voulais
pas avoir raté quelque chose en ce qui
concerne sur le capteur d'avril le
Conseil constitutionnel vous êtes
confiant
le gouvernement souhaite maintenir ce
texte très clairement la réforme des
retraites elle est nécessaire elle est
nécessaire pour les générations futures
gouverner c'est prendre des décisions
c'est prévoir c'est assumer aussi des
choix difficiles c'est ce que nous avons
fait avec cette réforme des retraites
nous le redisons il faut absolument
réformer l'air les retraites d'ailleurs
beaucoup pensent qu'il faut le réformer
certains ne sont pas allés jusqu'au bout
du jeu beaucoup de Français
et l'opinion est quand même assez forte
dans l'opposition assez très fin vous
pensez que si le Conseil valide le texte
les choses vont changer dans l'opinion
je pense que il faut que une fois que le
texte sera validé bien sûr il y aura
peut-être encore une opposition qui
s'exprimera et c'est légitime les
oppositions sont là pour s'exprimer je
crois que nous devons continuer ce
travail de pédagogie pour dire et pour
expliquer que cette réforme elle est
nécessaire une fois que le texte sera
validé je conserve ce futur bien
optimiste madame la ministre Fanny
guinothée on enchaîne une femme une 14
avril on sera là à la tête de la de la
CGT mais là qu'est-ce que je vois ça
c'est pas vous c'est vous pardonnez-moi
je pensais que c'était c'était Richard
Sophie Binet à la tête de la CGT bonne
nouvelle kiné absolument pas d'accord en
tout cas qui a eu envie d'être une des
premières opposantes à la réforme des
retraits
quelque chose quand même ce nouveau
visage à la CGT c'est même une petite
révolution parce que c'est une femme et
que dans ce syndicat centenaire il n'y
en a jamais eu il y en a eu sur d'autres
sur d'autres
syndicats par exemple à la CFDT mais
jamais à l'alcool et c'est un véritable
coup de jeune parce que Sophie Binet a
41 ans c'est une cadre aussi elle est à
la tête de la Fédération des ingénieurs
et des cadres elle ne vient pas du Parti
communiste ça aussi c'est quand même de
lunettes je crois elle vient du nef
c'est une féministe une écolo et elle
l'a dit elle incarne une envie de
changement à la tête de ce syndicat
parce que la CGT va changer alors ça
c'est une autre question
ça n'est pas sûr parce qu'effectivement
Sophie Binet a été élu désigné un peu en
tout cas contre toute attente on
s'attendait à un autre scénario sorti du
chapeau mais elle ce qu'elle va avoir
beaucoup de marge de manœuvre sachant
que derrière elle elle a eu le soutien
de fédération assez dur la Fédération
des transports incarnée par Laurent brun
qui est d'ailleurs son bras droit le
numéro 2 qui est à la tête de la de la
CGT SNCF et puis la Fédération par
exemple l'énergie ceux qui tiennent les
raffineries on voit qu'en ce moment ils
font quand même parler d'eux alors c'est
fédérations qui soutiennent ce féminin
sont plutôt pour un durcissement du
mouvement beaucoup plus que de netteté
finit parcinet et d'ailleurs elle l'a
dit Sophie Binet elle va aller au
rendez-vous avec Elisabeth borne demain
mais pas question de suspension de
médiation comme peut le demander Laurent
Berger c'est le retrait donc on imagine
que le rendez-vous avec la première mise
va couper court en tout cas ça risque
d'être assez rapide on verra d'ailleurs
si elle quitte précipitamment cette
réunion elle est donc plus dure que
Laurent Berger de la CFDT ça veut dire
que l'Inter cervicale peut s'éclater
peut s'arrêter en tout cas
l'intersyndical cette union là c'est
là-dessus que les syndicats ont retrouvé
crédit aux yeux des Français sont
revenus au centre du jeu c'est aussi
pour ça d'ailleurs que parce qu'ils
tiennent alors on dit l'Inter syndicale
CFDT CGT mais il y a 8 syndicats quand
même et puis des associations
d'étudiants qui depuis deux mois font
corps c'est aussi ce qui fait que
Elisabeth borne les reçoit demain cette
union là c'est quand même leur capital
le plus important reste que il faudra
voir parce que sur la stratégie
justement que vont adopter en tout cas
si j'étais CFDT ça risque d'être un
petit peu différent la CFDT a proposé je
le disais tout à l'heure de la médiation
Laurent Berger pour la discussion alors
que Sophie Binet visiblement n'est pas
du tout sur cette ligne là alors est-ce
que comment va se présenter ce duo
est-ce que Sophie Binet va challenger la
CFDT parce qu'on voit que c'est Laurent
Berger qui a pris le leadership de ce
mouvement c'est un peu ce qui nous
attend là dans les prochains jours à
suivre ça évidemment de près demain
Agnès Baudot toujours des félicitations
républicaines personne qui s'engagent et
prendre la tête d'un syndicat c'est
aussi un engagement et je lui souhaite
bon courage vous pensez que c'est des
consultations demain servent à quelque
chose avec les syndicats et la première
ministre toujours discuter c'est
important sur tous les sujets elles
arrivent elles arrivent pas un peu tard
dans les discussions ont lieu avant je
crois qu'il faut aussi arrêter de dire
que de il n'y a pas eu de discussion
avant la réforme des retraites que ce
soit Elisabeth borne que ce soit
49-3 elle reprenne parce que la volonté
de discuter elle a toujours été là et
que c'est en discutant qu'on peut faire
avancer les choses Richard va se
projeter maintenant sur le voyage
officiel d'Emmanuel Macron en Chine qui
vient dans ses valises avec une grande
européenne
Ursula vanderlagen la présidente de la
Commission européenne et vous nous dites
ce soir c'est tout sauf anecdotique et
oui Myriam la vérité c'est qu'il y a
deux Emmanuel Macron alors en plus
d'être l'apôtre du en même temps en
France le président s'apprête à endosser
deux rôles en Chine où il aura deux
entretiens avec son homologue si ginking
apk où il ne s'était plus rendu depuis
2019 Emmanuel Macron veut également
représenter l'Europe politique et
économique pour ça qu'il a habilement
proposé à Ursula wanderline d'être à ses
côtés pour l'un des deux entretiens
présidentielles il y en aura un autre
tout à fait français vous vous souvenez
que le chancelier allemand ou la folz
était lui allait tout seul en Chine en
novembre 2022 et vous avez peut-être
constaté la semaine dernière que le
président du Conseil espagnol Pedro
Sanchez lui aussi seul la France elle
marque donc un point c'est elle qui va
porter le drapeau bleu étoilé à Pékin à
un moment crucial pour l'Union vu les
très mauvais chiffres commerciaux
enregistrés par l'ensemble des 27 avec
la Chine
586 milliards d'euros d'échange en 2022
et
164 milliards d'euros de déficit pour un
milliard de dollars de marchandises
exportés vers la Chine et bien on en
importe 3 milliards c'est la même le
même tableau pour la France la Chine est
de loin le premier déficit commercial du
pays à hauteur de 31 milliards d'euros
une situation impossible à redresser
selon l'Élysée si les Européens ne font
pas bloc sauf que parmi les 27 tout le
monde n'est pas de cet avis alors je
vois Myriam que vous regardez encore du
côté de l'Allemagne et bien oui c'est
vrai Berlin a longtemps pensé que il
n'avait pas besoin de l'Europe pour leur
négociation commerciale avec Pékin le
déficit allemand a longtemps été
cantonné autour de 10 milliards d'euros
avec des exportations en grande forme
notamment pour le secteur automobile
sauf que ça change en 2022 un chiffre a
fait trembler le patronal allemand 84
milliards d'euros déficit commercial
pour 260 milliards d'échanges la réalité
et qui Emmanuel Macron prend les devants
habilement le président français est
convaincu que la dépendance européenne
vis-à-vis de la Chine dans des
technologies notamment pour la
transition climatique elle ne peut être
remise en cause qu'à 27 il veut aussi
conditionner à 27 l'accès chinois au
marché européen il veut parler à 27 de
l'accès des terres rares aux terres
rares bref c'est en européen qui
Emmanuel Macron va en Chine pour parler
business ah j'oubliais il y a un autre
énorme dossier celui de la guerre en
Ukraine mais là c'est une autre histoire
ah oui effectivement merci beaucoup
Richard Verly vous aimez la Chine
j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller deux fois en
Chine oui en tant que parlementaire avec
le groupe d'amitié avec la Chine je
crois que c'est important et il avait
très bien souligné que la France est à
travers le président de la République
soit le leader de cette union européenne
qui a en Chine je crois que c'est un
l'Europe qui doit faire face à la Chine
et c'est important qu'on puisse le faire
et que la France soit leader dans ce
domaine et ben c'est dit merci merci
beaucoup Agnès Firmin le Bodo d'être
venu une heure en direct sur LCP nous
parler de cette future loi sur la fin de
vie merci à vous les affranchis très
belle soirée sur SCP soirée documentaire
qui commence maintenant quant à moi je
vous dis à demain même heure
[Musique]